[Music]
both went to the same school yet someone
came back with a degree that's useful
and the other one came back is Asian
Ellen I cannot get enough of kids young
or crazy rich Asians by the way so when
are we going to see a sequel well that
was just one of the things I had to know
when we hit LA's mr. bones pumpkin patch
for a little Halloween adventure jump
and fly yeah what wait a minute how
about just a slide I've always thought
of myself as a leading man superhero
action stashed at Ken for Superman on
Twitter digging
[Music]
got it nothing to see here are your
girls are they into oh my girls are way
into it they're like they're like
costume changes it's like like it's like
two Asian Liza Minelli's in the house
it's like jeez Louise girls just can you
just take a break and maybe I don't know
read no I don't not on death day daddy I
make sure that I'm not doing anything on
Halloween Oh one time one time I I could
not go trick-or-treating with my kids
and hi and I was devastated
no bones about it Halloween is a big
deal in the Jeong family they go all out
for the holiday just like the Halloween
obsessed neighbor Ken plays in the
goosebumps sequel hey kids Wow you've
got quite a spread here so too much no
stand down Greg every single acting
choice I made on set was just like oh
god I think my kids will love this ya
know it you know it so what's next for
him well we'd love to see him back for
more crazy rich Asians I would love to
be the second one oh well maybe we do a
mash-up maybe crazy rich goosebumps
crazy rich gremlins crazy with zombies
anything at all about the sea I know
that is in the works right now being
development actors celebrities last to
know I need them to start shooting this
movie like yesterday right please but
here's the crazy thing
ken Jeong is a doctor it's no joke he
was a general practitioner and I still
can't get over that stand up was
actually his side hustles both hustles
worked out yes area wow they did
[Music]